>> Bill: AS YOU KNOW,
SCIENTISTS HAVE A DUTY TO NOT
LET POLITICS AFFECT THEIR
RESEARCH.
ONE NORTHWESTERN UNIVERSITY
PROFESSOR SAYING IN A "WALL
STREET JOURNAL" OP-ED IT IS
HAPPENING.
HE SAID SCIENTISTS CORRODE
PUBLIC TRUST WHEN THEY PRETEND
TO HAVE AUTHORITY ON SOCIAL AND
POLITICAL MATTERS.
WE THOUGHT OUR NEXT GUEST, THE
AUTHOR OF THE NEW BOOK, THE
DYING CITIZEN, WOULD BE PERFECT
FOR THIS TOPIC.
VICTOR DAVID HANSON.
GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
SCIENCE IS TO BE RESPECTED AND
EXPLORED.
WE ALL KNOW THAT.
IT IS ALSO TO BE QUESTIONED TO
MAKE SURE THE SCIENCE IS
CORRECT.
HOW DO YOU SEE THE POSITION OF
THIS PROFESSOR HERE?
>> I THINK HE IS ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT.
WHAT WE’VE DONE, BILL, IS
ENTRUSTED THESE UNELECTED
PEOPLE, BUREAUCRATS WITH
JUDICIAL, LEGISLATIVE AND
EXECUTIVE POWER.
DR. FAUCI PRACTICES THE NOBEL
LIE.
WEAR NO MASK, ONE MASK, TWO
MASKS.
WHEN CAUGHT HE SAID I DIDN’T DO
IT FOR YOUR OWN GOOD SO YOU
WOULDN’T BUY ALL THE MASKS UP.
HERD IMMUNITY, I KEPT CHANGING
THE FIGURE BECAUSE THE SCIENCE
WAS NECESSARY TO ADAPT TO SHOW
YOU THAT YOU STILL HAD TO GET
VACCINATED.
THE WORST, OF COURSE, AS PEOPLE
POINTED OUT IS NATURAL IMMUNITY
WAS SUPERIOR TO ACQUIRED BUT
DIDN’T WANT TO TELL YOU THAT
BECAUSE HE IS AFRAID THE
CITIZEN MIGHT SAY I’LL TAKE MY
CHANCES AND GET COVID.
IF I’M UNDER 60 IT’S 99 PLUS.
HE WAS AFRAID OF THAT AND THEY
WOULD GET COVID AND NOT HAVE TO
TAKE THE VACCINATION AND GET
SUPERIOR IMMUNITY.
HOW ABSURD IS DR. FAUCI.
IF YOU GET VACCINATED HE IS
SAYING IF YOU HAVE COVID YOU
STILL HAVE TO GET VACCINATED.
THE PEOPLE WITH COVID ARE
SAYING IF COVID ACQUIRED
IMMUNITY IS SUPERIOR DO I HAVE
TO -- DO THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
VACCINATED HAVE TO GO OUT AND
GET COVID SO THEY HAVE DOUBLE
PROTECTION LIKE YOU WANT ME TO
HAVE DOUBLE PROTECTION?
THIS IS COMMON, BUILD.
WE HAD THE 1200 HEALTHCARE
PROFESSIONALS SAYING THE MENTAL
HEALTH OF THE BLM RIOTERS WAS
MORE IMPORTANT THAN MASK
WEARING AND SOCIAL DISTANCING.
I’M DISGUSTED WITH IT.
EVERYBODY IS.
THEY DON’T LIKE THE NOBLE LIES.
JAMES CLAPPER WHEN HE LIED IF
YOU REMEMBER UNDER OATH AND
SAID THE NATIONAL SECURITY
AGENCY DOESN’T SURVEIL PEOPLE
AND WHEN CAUGHT HE SAID WELL, I
ONLY GAVE THE LEAST UNTRUTHFUL
ANSWER.
THOSE 50 LETIRED C.I.S. EXPERT
SCIENTISTS SAID HUNTER BIDEN’S
LAPTOP IS PROBABLY RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION AND THEY DID IT
BECAUSE THEY THOUGHT IT WAS
NOBLE NOT TO SEE JOE BIDEN LOSE
THE ELECTION.
>> Bill: I WOULD JUST ARGUE.
>> THESE PEOPLE ARE DANGEROUS.
>> Bill: IF SCIENCE TAKES YOU
IN A DIFFERENT DIRECTION YOU
HAVE TO CHANGE YOUR FEELING ON
THAT.
THIS OP-ED WRITES LAST YEAR IN
MONTANA’S GLACIER PARK THEY HAD
TO REMOVE SIGNS THAT GLACIERS
WOULD BE GONE BY THE YEAR 2020.
THAT’S AN IRONY THERE INTO
ITSELF.
THE GOVERNOR OF TEXAS, GREG
ABBOTT, HAD A BREAKTHROUGH CASE
WITH COVID AND JUST THIS WEEK
HE SIGNED AN EXECUTIVE ORDER
BANNING THE VACCINE MANDATES.
NOW, ASSUME THAT HIS POSITION
IS BASED ON SCIENCE, HOW DO YOU
FEEL ABOUT A GOVERNOR OF A VERY
LARGE STATE LIKE THAT TAKING
THAT POSITION?
>> WELL, I THINK WHAT HE IS
SAYING IS I HAVE INFORMED
CITIZENS AND I SERVE AT THEIR
BEHEST AND THEY ARE RATIONAL
PEOPLE AND WILL MAKE A DECISION
THAT IF THEY ARE UNDER 60 AND
IT’S VERY UNLIKELY THEY WILL
DIE FROM COVID AND THEY MAY
PREFER TO TAKE THEIR CHANCES
RATHER THAN GET A VACCINATION,
I DIDN’T DO THAT.
I DON’T RECOMMEND IT BUT I
WON’T TELL SOMEBODY THAT
ACQUIRED IMMUNITY IS NOT AS
GOOD AS A VACCINATION WHEN THE
SCIENCE SAYS OTHERWISE BECAUSE
I’M NOBLY GOING TO LIE AND HOPE
THEY’LL GET OTHERWISE
VACCINATED.
THAT’S WHAT HE IS TRYING TO
TELL PEOPLE.
THAT I’M GOING TO GIVE YOU THE
FACTS AND LET YOU MAKE THE
DECISION BECAUSE I TRUST YOUR
JUDGMENT MORE THAN I DO ANTHONY
FAUCI.
REMEMBER FAUCI IS A PERSON WHO
ROUTED 600,000 DOLLARS THROUGH
ECHO HEALTH IN SOME INSANE IDEA
TO PROMOTE WHAT WAS
GAIN-OF-FUNCTION RESEARCH AT
THE VIROLOGY LAB IN WUHAN THAT
WAS GROUND ZERO OF THE PANDEMIC
AND STILL DENIES IT IS
GAIN-OF-FUNCTION RESEARCH.
A CITIZEN WOULDN’T DO THAT.
NOBODY WOULD ELECT A
REPRESENTATIVE TO DO THAT.
ONLY SOMEBODY WHO IS
UNACCOUNTABLE TO THE PEOPLE HAS
THAT LATITUDE AND POWER.
YET WE’RE NOT SUPPOSED TO GET
UPSET ABOUT IT.
TO THIS DAY HE WON’T TELL US
WHY HE ROUTED THAT $600,000 OR
WHETHER IT IS OR NOT GAIN OF
FUNCTION AND THE SCIENCE
SUGGESTED HE IS INCORRECT.
>> Bill: FAIR POINT.
MIKE GALLAGHER CONGRESSMAN IS
COMING UP IN 45 MINUTES ON THAT
TOPIC ABOUT WUHAN AND WHAT THE
ACCESS IS OR ISN’T.
FAUCI ONCE SAID IF YOU ARE
SEEING ATTACKS ON ME QUITE
FRANKLY THOSE ATTACKS ARE ON
SCIENCE.
HIS QUOTE.
VICTOR DAVID HANSON.
>> WE HAVE A LOT OF CULT
FIGURES AND RELIGIOUS FIGURES
THROUGHOUT HIS RE WHO SAID IF
YOU DOUBT MY WORD YOU ARE AN
APOSTATE OR IRRELIGIOUS.
HE IS TREATING SCIENCE AS A
RELIGION WRAPPED UP IN HIS OWN
PERSONA.
HE SHOULD SAY LOOK AT THE DATA.
USE THE SCIENTIFIC METHOD AND
SEE IF I’M ON THE RIGHT OR
WRONG SIDE OF SCIENCE AND MAKE
YOUR OWN DECISIONS NOT TRUST ME